hello there
welcome to playstation grenade the new
season of fortnite battle royale is here
and it's packed with marvel goodness
if you're new around these parts this is
the series in which we look at
everything that has changed on the
island
from the monumental to the minuscule
from the new pois
to gnomes with brutus masks on we'll get
to that one soon
please think about using code adamaru to
support these shenanigans
and let's uncover the secrets of
fortnite chapter 2
season 4 hit the music
[Music]
first let's rewind a few days to reveal
the marvel tie-in
and thor's hammer crashing down near
salty springs
a few days ago we all tried to lift the
mighty mjolnir but to no
avail in game though right now the
hammer is gone
thor has reclaimed it leaving a divot in
the ground
the hammer may have only been there a
few days but those
were good memories each of the marvel
characters who were brought to the
island by lady siff
used the bifrost to travel and each of
them
left behind a scorched mark on the
ground which can be found
to the south of the authority on this
hillside
you can hear the grass singing in the
heat which is a really cool touch
close by the most wow factor update of
the season can be found a group
of perished sentinels these mutant
hunting robots were a key part of the
x-men comics back in the 1990s
and by the looks of them they've already
bumped into wolverine and storm
the detail here is phenomenal it's also
a perfect spot for taking photos
like a high five with this guy and i am
i can't explain this
shot i have no idea what penny is doing
to that guy's junk
a thing of note is the broken building
this fight has left
wreckage and will likely be rebuilt over
the coming season
maybe repurposing those sentinel parts
too
[Music]
let's move away from big changes for a
moment and look at a petite one
get your butt into the authority and
look what's going down
this poi is being packed away a big
change is coming soon
all the memorabilia is in boxes and webs
and dust are taking over
sadly it looks like the brutus storyline
we've been building towards
is no more well that's what i thought
until i went into the rafters
here is a secret shrine to brutus his
mask
his picture and his love interest are
here
there is way more to find out isn't
there let's unpack that another day
we got map secrets to find also note
though there is a henchman here who
won't attack
unless provoked and there's also another
one at retail row
we'll get to that very soon just outside
the authority look in the water and
you'll spot the foundations of the old
wall i wonder why they kept the
foundations
is this place going to change again if
we had to guess will this become
avengers tower
or a stronghold to fight off galactus in
the live event i can't wait to find out
is anyone big brained enough to predict
what will happen here on the island
onto more huge stuff and the update at
pleasant park
wow this place has been flooded it's
been rebuilt and now dr doom has taken
residence here
his castle home is filled with images of
himself
which is kind of weird right so i took
it upon myself to redecorate slightly
much better i'm sure you'll agree in the
basement we can spot a prison cell which
could be something in the future but the
best part
is in the loft doctor doom has a man
cave complete with an evil villain desk
oh and there's also a vault under the
soccer field football pitch whatever you
want to call it you do you
this is a really impressive poi now and
undoubtedly this will be one of the
hottest drops for the rest of the season
so i visited the farm to check up on the
hayman
and holy shizzle my nizzle he has gone
i searched everywhere and even tried to
find him where the original iron man was
remember back in the day we always
thought they would meet up but last
season the pikeman was lost to the flood
so i thought about giving up but then i
visited the castle ruins and
lo and behold this wholesome goodness
the bros
finally found each other an epic high
five ensues
back when chapter two began we begged
epic to let these two behemoths meet up
and now perfection has arrived and to
keep a joke we do at the start of every
season
if you come here and high five these
bros you will win the game 110 percent
it's true just check the comments
fortnite hacks
confirmed
[Music]
here's a very interesting update
remember crack shots cabin
this place has now gone and has been
replaced
with a farmhouse tony stark is currently
building here and it feels a great deal
like the work of the scientist
in season x back then the thick visitor
made rift beacons which became
new pois all season long and look at
what iron man is doing now
these red solar power units are found
everywhere on the island
could he be doing something similar to
adapt the island in coming weeks
fingers crossed he can change the island
and while we're talking about tony stark
i'm sure you've noticed the stark
tech and bots which can be found near
the quinjets defended by bots
i mean real bots not players like me we
can grab new
tech but one site is better than the
rest
as it has a punching bag if i could play
the rocky theme tune right now i'd be
all over it
now let's go over to retail row a new
building has arrived here
the offices of jennifer walters she's
the lady who becomes
she-hulk in the comic books after a
blood transfusion with dr banner
how cool is it that she has a direct
tie-in subtle enough to miss
but there for the fans of marvel to
notice i love it here in retail road
there is also a single building which
has changed every season
it was once a halloween star it then
became a christmas shop
and then it became a face-off between
ghost and shadow
and as you know shadow kicked buttocks
and this place became their
office but today things have changed
again
the sign outside has been removed and
inside just like the authority
the cleanup has begun shadow are no more
and like usual there's a cool easter egg
to be found for us map change fanatics
check him out graeme the gnomes minion
wearing a brutus mask and carrying an
ego file
how meta can one character be i wonder
if graham has a new plan
oh and also note here the brutus image
is being taken down the same one as the
authority
we never got the answers we deserved am
i missing something right now or is the
brutus sub story
over i'm not ready for it to be over
with that in mind
i traveled over to the grotto brutus's
original home to see if it was still
sealed and flooded
and yeah yeah it is but then i saw this
lines in the water which usually
indicate something will change here
later in the season
so it may not change right away but
later in season 4 something will be
added to this poi
and hopefully give us some more brutus
goodness or maybe this will become black
panther's rock mountain
like in the comic books or the film
black panther predictions let's do this
[Music]
want to see another weird update well
get your butt over to camp cod
the place has changed back to the
pre-flood era
but there is something which is very
strange go inside the building and you
will find a house full of urns
and vases these vars phases
vases how the heck do you say that word
anyway it's weird here look at it
in fact all around the map the cleanup
has begun to remove
shadow from existence some pois though
have vanished completely
deadpool's yacht is no more and that
random fishing porch we had three weeks
ago
that's gone too the one near steamy
stacks down in weeping woods the
buildings have been reset
but look at the rv outside wolverine has
been here
the only other update in the woods is
where the misfit genome war started in
the bunker under a cabin
today all those characters have been
removed and it looks like this
this will become a place for shield to
monitor the island
so i checked on other outposts and yes
shadow is being deleted from existence
everything is being renovated midas
legacy
will soon be forgotten remember all
those ritual sites we can find
everywhere on the island they have the
icons of gods of elements like water
fire
thunder that sort of thing well there is
a brand new one that has been added this
season and it's at the top of
this mountain it looks like a place for
thor to regain his powers
maybe as part of a quest line for him or
maybe storm
hmm let's watch this place hang on i
feel like there's something missing here
there it is hot watch is continuing to
grow
this week the fencing is in place on the
first layer
it's slow progress at this rate we could
have an official poi by i don't know
chapter
seven maybe fingers crossed i'd watch
forever
next i double checked on graham to make
sure he was okay
and yeah he's fine and the radio tower
he lives in hasn't had any changes at
all
but that's when i noticed in the sky we
can actually see galactus approaching
extremely slowly the live event at the
end of the season is going to blow our
minds
hopefully we'll see the avengers take
down galactus using their unique powers
and maybe we'll join in too up to this
point we've spectated in live events
could this be the season we become
integral to the story and join in one
more thing to go over
and it's a big thing of the season the
crustaceans
last season we watched as the wobbly
blobs began to go through the evolution
of man
wobbly blubs i say stupid stuff don't i
anyway they built a small colony they
pillaged the seas as pirates
they created egyptian sculptures and
then
a city to be proud of then they got a
bit ahead of themselves they made a
rocket sent it into space
and finally they caused a nuclear
mushroom cloud to eviscerate themselves
right now they live like this what
has gone on here it's like a colony of
cyborgs pat crustacean part robot
if this was a dc season i'd suggest a
different comic book hero was involved
but right now the crustaceans are
evolving quicker than we could ever
expect
any guesses on what will happen next
so there we have it a metric ton of
updates and we didn't even talk about
fishing
let me know if i've missed anything and
i'll include it next week
on screen now are a bunch of awesome
people who've used code adamarro in the
store i thank you i really appreciate
you next time i'll be naming all the
battle pass legends
so look out for that next time i'm adam
from playstation grenade it's been a
pleasure
i'll see you next time
[Music]
[Applause]
you